[Musica]
d'elia garaventa joseph germanotta
silvio ciccone teresa augello e adele
zirilli cinque italiani cinque italiani
tra i tanti che i vari momenti del
secolo scorso hanno intrapreso un
viaggio in america la ricerca di un
futuro migliore
così come tanti altri italiani nel
secolo scorso si sono mischiati poi alla
società americana hanno messo su
famiglia che da queste famiglie sono
nati poi in ordine frank sinatra
lady gaga madonna alicia keys bruce
springsteen artisti per i quali
spendiamo con grande entusiasmo la
parola italo americano come se fossero
facenti parti più netti e un'etnia a sé
stante sappiamo benissimo che non è così
sono artisti americani ma ci piace
ricordare e la loro appartenenza a
questo paese
se poi allarghiamo l'orizzonte sempre
rimanendo nella musica del novecento del
rock and roll e nei suoi derivati
gli esempi diventano infiniti frank
poole sarà da a zanzibar si trasferisce
l'inghilterra e fonda un gruppo che si
chiamano i queen con lo pseudonimo di
freddie mercury george panayiota artista
greco cipriota affonda gli one e poi
prosegue la sua carriera come george
michael
bob marley il principe della musica
giamaicana e della cultura rastafariana
di madre giamaicana e di padre bianco
inglese john bates cantatrice che
difende i diritti dei giovani americani
di padre messicano bob dylan con nonni
lituani e ucraini e potremmo andare
avanti all'infinito alla conclusione
korea ma che la maggior parte della
musica occidentale è fatta da gente che
di occidentale spesso ben poco è altra
cosa è che attraverso la musica
noi possiamo in qualche modo conoscere
meglio le origini di queste persone i
popoli da cui questi musicisti
provengono
se pensiamo al brasile l'argentina
l'africa nera sub sahariana a cuba
pensiamo a dei popoli che ci mettono
allegria perché il samba il tango la
musica percussiva del centrafrica che
tutti almeno una volta nella vita
abbiamo ballato o la salsa c
predispongono positivamente nei
confronti di un di un popolo a noi
sconosciuto e i musicisti che vengono da
questi paesi che noi chiamiamo il sud
del mondo negli ultimi 30 anni con
l'accentuarsi dei fenomeni migratori
sono arrivati in forze in in europa e in
italia abbiamo cominciato a conoscere
strumenti musicali e noi sino a quel
momento sconosciuti con dei nomi
abbastanza complicati cora hood qena
djembe sabar dum dum tutt'altra cosa
rispetto al violino o alla chitarra
elettrica e per questi musicisti che ci
fanno ascoltare le loro canzoni spesso e
lingue incomprensibili
abbiamo coniato l'espressione musica
etnica come se questo tipo di musica
raccontasse a differenza dell'altra
musica l'appartenenza a un popolo
io non sono un etto musicologo e quindi
non vada avanti con teorie complicate
anche per me sono un musicista musicista
romano sono il contrabbasso e ho
conosciuto prima la musica multietnica
di quella etnica questo parolone
contemporaneo che a roma ha cominciato
ad emergere circa 15 anni fa quando un
musicista casertano mario tronco e un
regista pugliese 2 anche loro immigrati
agostino ferrente hanno avuto l'idea di
formare un'orchestra che si chiama
orchestra di piazza vittorio della quale
io faccio fieramente parte dall'inizio
evviva
questa orchestra ha come dire è
diventata un modello di riferimento per
molti altri musicisti italiani che hanno
formato in altre città anche a roma in
altre città italiane altre orchestre
dove sempre si sono uniti in realtà
musicisti italiani a musicisti stranieri
che sono arrivati in italia per cercare
un futuro migliore come gli italiani che
un secolo fa andavano in america da cui
sono nati gli artisti che abbiamo
parlato all'inizio e come gli stessi
italiani andavano in america e cercavano
di mischiarsi alla società americana
così questi musicisti si sono mischiati
alla società italiana si sono innamorati
delle donne italiane è cosa facile
hanno messo su famiglia e come spesso
succede
i figli dei musicisti vogliono fare
anche loro i musicisti è infatti non
rifacciamo è infatti è infatti uno di
questi fi che sono proprio io mi chiamo
simone ndiaye ho 18 anni e sono nella
piccola orchestra di torpignattara che
un gruppo che è nato cinque anni fa
grazie all'idea di domenico coduto che è
un uomo che si è trasferito qui a roma
da benevento
quindi se vogliamo quando è più
straniero de medici amo appunto portando
i figli a passeggio per i parchi si è
reso conto della presenza di moltissimi
ragazzi e ragazzi un po scorretti con
gli occhi un po a mandorla quindi
apparentemente stranieri ma che tra di
loro parlavano in dialetto romano
avevano gli stessi usi e costumi dei
loro coetanei nati e cresciuti qui qui
in italia i cosiddetti immigrati di
seconda generazione e io sono uno di
loro
per comodità immagino è stata coniata la
sigla a 2 g la sigla due gemma quindi
dal mio figlio sarà poi 3g
4 g5 g6 g ma che siamo iphone
vabbè è appunto inizialmente abbiamo
cominciato a suonare la musica che
piaceva ai nostri padri a lui
soprattutto crescendo ci siamo resi
conto che quel tipo di musica non ci
rappresentava noi siamo nati e cresciuti
qui siamo nati e cresciuti con la musica
occidentale nelle orecchie
diciamo mio padre stesso percussionista
senegalese avrebbe voluto vedermi
suonare le percussioni in un gruppo
senegalese
io tutto suono o meno che le percussioni
in un gruppo senegalese e vorrebbe
segretamente di serie d'armi penso
perché sono il basso elettrico anche in
un gruppo di metal per esempio i padri
africani
e quindi abbiamo crescendo evolvendoci
si è voluto anche l'orchestra e abbiamo
cominciato a capire che il messaggio che
volevamo diffondere volevamo diffonderlo
con un linguaggio musicale più vicino a
noi
uno di questi linguaggi e hip hop il rap
quello che tutti quanti abbiamo sentito
sentiamo sentiremo per un bel po di
tempo spero niente adesso vi faremo
vedere come dei musicisti apparentemente
filippini nigeriani egiziani ricordo
manco le razze ormai appunto come
riusciamo a diffondere questo messaggio
grazie all'hip hop grazie
[Applauso]
cisco roma sintomi in tasca fissare al
fumo di resta e shariah ecuador egitto
solo pari per favore
[Musica]
nel tuo sguardo si riflette via
siamo tutti ben sofferto devo sentire
tutti fa da roma fino a dirsi felici ora
ti rispondo bella serata
ma già la pasta siamo tutti uniti tutti
che la stessa razza maurizio siate più
bassa ma se non futuro klp farebbe la
mia fosse nel gol ispirazione da quello
cinese
tutti sotto una stessa nazione bottacin
che potesse avere un milione te prima
che fare il seno del fen quartiere 4
centocelle tutti sabato per chi gli ha
scritto che rimetta in sesto e del sano
e sicuro
la veloce di questa lettera d'amore
quella musica dell'anima e la
trasmissione
e al 4 tutte le cose di sicuro la voce
di questa città lati da lavorare con la
musica il posto dell'anima nella sua
ambizioni la forza di questa realtà
cerca di quello che ci fa
[Applauso]
ma con i colori di questa città nati
dall'amore con la musica posto
dell'anima nella tradizione di la forza
di questa realtà come uccelli con
ricerca di libertà a pazzo siamo
veramente italiane incredibile
parliamo davvero italiano allora questi
quattro ragazzi li hanno cantato una
canzone che si intitola il mondo in
tasca che in realtà è il nostro primo
pezzo scritto assieme
quattro anni fa quando il più grande di
loro forse aveva 14 anni e mi
rispettavano molto di più
purtroppo crescendo peggiorano ma io li
amo lo stesso dalí e noi siamo andati
avanti questa marca strache fa attività
lavorate laboratoriali costantemente
tutte le settimane abbiamo ospitato più
di 60 tra ragazzi e ragazze immigrati di
seconda generazione italiani minori non
accompagnati richiedenti asilo vediamo
un po di tutto cercando di portare
avanti il questo discorso cioè noi
vogliamo fare musica nuova stimolare i
ragazzi alla creatività perché pensiamo
che chi è percepito donne come diverso
debba avere gli stessi strumenti che
all'indigeno per esprimere le proprie
idee perché questa è l'unica possibilità
che abbiamo per creare i presupposti di
una società migliore della nostra il
prossimo pezzo che ascolteremo con cui
poi vi saluteremo con una parte più
numerosa di orchestra noi siamo tutti in
realtà siamo 25 si intitola under ed è
il loro punto di vista sul razzismo
razzismo che secondo loro è qualcosa che
appartiene dal medioevo appartiene a noi
vecchi adulti e che è qualcosa che va
va superato lo ha superato con il loro
linguaggio
noi dal canto nostro e loro ci auguriamo
di finalmente poter trovare una casa a
roma una casa grande dove poter perché
no far dialogare le due orchestre dove
gli stranieri e dell'orchestra di piazza
vittorio insegnino il loro punto di
vista agli italiani della piccola
orchestra di torpignattara e viceversa
perché questo secondo noi il modo per
far sì che veramente si possa aprire la
pista è una strada a una nuova idea
d'italia dove dove si possa essere
orgogliosi dei propri figli di quelli
che avranno successo così come oggi allo
stesso modo abbiamo orgoglio per gli
artisti italo americani si possa
cominciare essere orgogliosi di artisti
egiziano italiano ecuadoregno italiano
filippino italiano senegalese italiano
e così via buonanotte andar piccola
orchestra perché mi attacco
insomma navette blog blog di frenata 12
paure 4 ma le posso fare lui sì sento
quale va alla società lo vuole
immaginare a parlare di questa
situazione siamo stanchi non lo vedi che
li prova le emozioni come gli ati ma
tutti quanti non importa niente ma con
la convinzione che resterà per sempre
non esiste uffici tore presente c'è chi
lotta incessantemente contro tutta
questa gente non sopporto più la falsità
di questa società che dà una certa la
diversità ed è per questo che a disagio
e la paura perché solo e combatte senza
la propria armatura se qualcuno
conoscenze labbra po diversa e promossi
macinare qual è la realtà capirebbe che
cos'è la sensibilità
coniugare sport
[Musica]
si avvicina la pala o la corte
lei si dice
per accessi l'anno
[Musica]
il suo marchio back to black fare la
domanda non si pone come una lacrima che
non voglia sono cresciute nel quartiere
dove stanno a vedere cose negli occhi ed
ho il mio colore e dentro un po di piove
anche se fuori c'è il sole
cerco la libertà dentro questi sette
note e tu che parli di disperazione
perché horizon e marcorè
qualche la mia gente i miei fratelli
cuore è stato un simbolo pezzi che non
ti senti fusina certo c'è la
sorveglianza di vetro sia intorno e non
credo a quello che è vero che
personalità distinte come alter ego
talmente bianco sia di quasi la quale si
era casuale fumetto cecina lingue
[Musica]
ma io la storia tra telethon
all
azione lido
come magliana
le tematiche libera
tipica 2 cucchiai di todi pg 20 giorni
ma di notte
ha preferito che vada
basta guardare quando manda mente
pratica
the pluck di persona buona e salsa sai
wioletta braille questo quando ha letto
brani del grande sì
questa sì
le capacità
[Musica]
[Applauso]